good evening you little uh
uh turkish game hens
remember turkish game hen
dude i remember my mother went on a date
or something one time
she'd met a man and
they got married years later and he was
a uh
he did a
he ran a corn operated car wash
you know
you could pat him on the back and hear
the quarters in him that kind of guy you
know local guy
and i remember they
i guess i don't know if he invited us
over to his house like the first time
he ever invited us over mr charlie they
called him big charlie
they called him that
right up until uh
he died
and
um what are they talking about
oh i'll tell you this so
big charlie
he had us over for some turkish game hen
turkish gay man is that it tur
is it torquis
torcus what's that color
turquoise game hint turquoise game here
no turkish game hen turkish game hen
three three sounds
um he had us over for some turkish game
in
turkish game in say that ten times fast
huh turkish game man tucker's gaming
turkish came in
uh
oh i just
this gala that i know um
told me that if you say
rise
rise up lights
it sounds like razor blades in australia
try it i bet you will laugh if you if
you do try it rise up lights
rise up lights
have you been what have you been doing
you've been having some rise up lights
rise up lights
you're gonna just walk into a hardware
store later and be like rise up lots
um
but yeah big charlie he had us over for
some turkish gaming i mean dan we're
poor as hell
and you bring us over for these little
fancy ass uh
you know little french pigeons man these
[ __ ]
i mean the shoulder muscles i remember
the shoulders were just so like that
deltoid
and i remember sitting at it just trying
to look nice like we'd never been over
there and
we had i think i don't know if my mom
had made them just
just trying to be outside of our means
you know like damn give me a damn
mcnugget baby you know give me a damn uh
hot uh
hot dog
you know give me something that i could
that'll
that'll that'll you know my stomach is
even gonna recognize you send this
little bad little
this little money pigeon in this little
turkish game
uh hand in
my system doesn't know what to you know
that's like when a uh
a realtor you know walks into a homeless
camp you know what i'm saying it's gonna
be a little
what do you this is you know
what are you why are you in here
um
but big charlie had us over there for
them turkish game ends and then
and then years later he would die by the
uh
but i remember just seeing that little
pigeon but like i i felt bad eating it
it looked like a damn little uh
sarcophagus of a damn
you know a famous bird or something
you know maybe one of those birds that
have been in world war ii those little
um
you ever see the pigeon with a little
backpack on it
that's when we could use pigeons as
spies
remember that
i went to the museum over there in
philadelphia
over there with a city of brotherly love
man
and they got some brothers who'll beat
the love right out of you too if you're
out there near temple late at night
but uh
we talking about oh
out near philadelphia
yeah that little turkey oh i went to the
spy museum and they showed the pigeons
in there with the backpack
and that's when animals used to do
something
you know you used to see animals doing
work
seeing eye dog
uh
spy pigeon
um what else
uh
those uh cola bears those sh uh
coca-cola coke ba you know the
polar the coke bears and [ __ ] up
there
sl
test driving that freaking sugar
that sugar supper
so you and i don't have to they up there
on that in the arctic
that's a job they can do if they hired
humans to go up there we would
you know we wouldn't even be able to
keep this [ __ ] warm a polar bear they
hold something in their hand in them you
know keep it so warm
they'll melt the damn chocolate if it's
entertaining you can't a polar bear
can't even hold the chocolate
that's sad man polar bear can't even
hold a chocolate because it just
it'll just do too much heat through it
you love a little thing of chocolate
soup in your hand
but r.i.p big charlie man he uh
had us over for those game hands and
fancy ass little
you know i did i felt damn sad eating
that little [ __ ]
it looked like a damn newborn uh chicken
it just looked like it had never had a
chance you know it thing was built real
small and just the deltoids on it
i remember look like floyd mayweather
look a little [ __ ] look like damn uh
uh
sugar's ray leonard man
look like damn sugar's ray leonard baby
i'll say this man i the other day i saw
a guy in a uh
i want to be honest with you i want to
be honest the other day i saw a guy in a
leather jacket at a mexican restaurant
if you wear a leather jacket at a
mexican restaurant well you can just
stay away from me
you can stay away
from me
from me uh
because i don't need that kind
halloween is over and i don't need to
see no more
of the damn
uh
pandora's box
escapees running around if you wear
a
leather jacket to a mexican restaurant
you can stay away from me
do you hear that
because i feel like some of you don't
hear if you wear a leather jacket to a
mexican restaurant you can stay away
from me because i am
[Music]
a better man than that
let's get into it baby thank you guys
for being here with me today and thank
you for being a part of my lifestyle
[Music]
come on
we coming up baby
89 both
i'm gonna come up
[Music]
well i just broke up with my
well i just moved up to lucky street
when the mayor came and said
[Music]
is
that's um
89 v 89 volt
with the come up
and there we are coming up into november
man november
that was always an interesting time of
year when i was young
after halloween had gone there was so
much big energy heading into halloween
you know what are you gonna be what you
know where where where are you going how
do we is there gonna be candies there
you know i don't have any face paint we
i remember we come home and just basic i
remember
you know sometimes we didn't plan ahead
at my house
and obviously nobody planned ahead if
they had four children and
you know when the dad was in his 70s
there was very little planning going on
um
but as child as a child we did you know
we just so suddenly we'd get home for it
would be the day the night of halloween
we didn't want to have anything
no preparatory
you know when mom had bought um
raggedy andy costumes one year so those
[ __ ] were
going around you know and then it was uh
i remember we cut the
it was raggedy ann those are the ones
mom had bought her dad had bought
and then we cut the hair on them
bastards one time so we
next thing you know you raggedy ann uh
now you raggedy andy you cut them
[ __ ] real
you a little soft in the cheeks kind of
glistening cheeks raggedy andy
g chicken
and then we cut the hair even more you
know and then you kind of trans you
trans
you know
you right you know
you
you tragedy you know you out there you
don't even know put to put it in the bag
put it in my hand you know i'll balance
you know who are you doing you know
that's the lord's shell game right there
baby out there transiting out
and then they some i remember i think my
brother burned the uh hair off the damn
thing so then you got there you cancer
uh or chemo
andy you chemo andy now now you
you remember we do a fake iv into the
arm and
uh
one year my uh i did chemo andy and my
brother did
um
he was like a pastor like the
the death
the you know the last pastor you see
that little death
that little death bouncer
you know that little uh
the guy who's like kind of a little kind
of a creepy position i'ma come over
while you die you know what i'm saying
that's a little
you know kind of the mike tyson of the
pastor kingdom i feel like he's like i'm
gonna put you to sleep
speaking of death liquid death right
here
oh
oh murder your thirst
yeah but i remember that and then uh
yeah we'd be out you know it's just
funny the evolution of a costume you see
a lot
you would see in our area our home
um what else
yeah but it's interesting you coming to
this time of year and now it's like this
mad dash to christmas i literally
feel like there's a starting line and
everybody's just like
and there's going to be one water table
you stop and get a cup of water that's
thanksgiving
and then it's
it's just a mad dash to the end of the
year
um
but i do like the the weather in the air
getting crisp
you know this when i was young this is
the time of year you'd see a lot of
stray animals come through
because they'd be done partying for the
summer or done you know out
you know some of them would have
maybe i guess been i guess in the
mountains for the summer i don't know
where i guess an animal trying to stay
cool would be in the mountains so i
guess they come down from the mountains
at that time of year during winter to
stay to get into a house or to stay warm
you know to stay at the same you know
stay at a
good healthy uh
room temperature but outdoor room
porch uh
so
anyway you see a lot of animals stray
animals come through and i love a stray
animal you don't see them anymore
you know back in the day animals used to
be brave enough like all right you know
i've had a good time here mom and dad
you know i'm gonna go out and
try out the universe
you know i'm gonna put my backpack on or
my front pack if they you know however
they traveled or whatever and
and then i'm gonna get out you know i'm
gonna get out and try out the world i'm
going to do well
you'll i'll make you proud
you know i'm going to be an extra and
babe pig in the city you know i'm going
to be an extra in madagascar
you know that animals would you'd see
you see a stray animal come through
you'd see something pass by you know a
little chimpanebra or something
you know you'd see a little uh
you know you'd see a little monkey with
maybe a little you know he'd have a
little pail or something inside of it
would be like a little bichon
you know you'd see stray animals come
through
and a stray animal was it was like the
lewis and clark of animals you know you
don't know where that [ __ ] had been
you know you like what's going on buddy
tell me where you know
give me some what's happening
he's got a narcan he's got a narcan
needle in his chest he's
you know he's got a tattoo of a frisbee
on his arm
he's been through he's like yeah i was
at the park man they're close to parks
they're closed up parks
anyway
what am i talking about i don't know who
does know who does know but i do like
this time of year
you know you see because winter's coming
so animals need to make a choice
that's when nature chooses to do a few
things
you know the trees go to sleep inside
themselves the leaves fall off
it's kind of naughty it's like the the
tree's saying all right i'm gonna get
naked but
i'm gonna shut it down i'm going to
sleep be like damn come on
stay up for an hour you know what i'm
saying
let me climb them branches mom
let me climb them branches mama
um
what else thank you uh
everybody for supporting the uh
the netflix special that's out
it's been nice
um
i'm looking in the news right now it
says here carol baskin suing netflix
over tiger king too
carol's about that
carol's that you know
she's such that she's like such a tight
she's like the
karen it feels like of the tiger kingdom
and i think we might have gotten a video
from carol
uh
when we did that christmas spectacular
show last year
we might have got a video sent in from
her i'm not sure if so i'll see if a
cameo see if we can put in this episode
but um
hey all you cool cats and kittens it's
carol baskin from big cat rescue
theo and tammy i'm so happy to see you
together here in the new year
i hope you and all of your fans have a
perfect 2021
and remember the big cats always get the
best beef
tiger king 2 she argues that producers
are simply rehashing repackaging unused
stuff to make it seem like she has given
new interviews or insight
that's every
sequel that's all that is all the
documentaries the second one now is just
uh
they interview one like outside
character
they'll interview probably a real tiger
they'll probably interview tony the
tiger
he's like i don't know you know i was
eating kellogg's i don't know i don't
know
you know i don't i'm shocked what they
were doing to these other tigers
i'm just a drawing so
if i'm hungry they draw me a steak they
draw me a uh
bird
so
that's it they're saying they're going
you know she's gonna sue them good for
carol sit look
sue him
sue it that's where we it's just people
suing each other every day
people suing not shocked sue netflix
also they should also be sued for
putting on um
that new colin kaepernick show
i think at some point
you're just creating content to
start real life
trouble
that's what i think i think
it just felt like pandering
to
race
racism that was just
it just felt like the lowest common
denominator for racial pandering
that's what it felt like
and it felt like it takes away from real
stuff that happens
or realer instances
um that's what it felt like to me now
i'm also a white guy
saying this
but
it just oh
it just felt sad
it just felt like you guys can do better
and you could put your face on something
better
um
but
that's uh you know
i'm a polish nicaraguan bad boy i don't
know ever you know i don't know anything
so but that [ __ ] felt [ __ ] cheap
um
kaepernick also in the news after
comparing being an nfl athlete to being
a slave he was slammed after this they
said
yeah that seemed like a lot a lot of
difference
a lot of difference
um
big difference
big difference been than being on the
49ers and being on the
zaire
slave
boat
i mean
that's you guys travel in a way
different class of travel that alone
a lot different
um
i think we all feel like slaves
sometimes colin when it comes to like
our jobs and stuff
but sometimes that's work
you could call it slavery if you want
you could also call it having a job
but let's move on sorry i don't know why
i'm even getting into that it's just on
the news list
um
what else elon musk becomes the first
person to be worth more than 300 billion
dollars
um
not shocked dude
if you don't see what's going on
there's about 30 people that have all
the money
okay
elon musk
jeff bezos
milton bradley
brennan shaub
um
and i don't know who else
probably a lot of politicians or former
politicians
uh they are all taking trips to space
because obviously something is about to
happen here i think on earth
i think maybe something's about to
happen man and maybe there's like 10 or
20 people that are gonna get to keep
going
you know maybe they'll have a draft or
something uh
maybe they'll have a draft and you get
to see what it's like but
yeah there's going to be 10 or 20 people
keep going
um
and why do they pick colin kaepernick
for this story couldn't you pick
somebody that's had a real real struggle
that i think that's something i do not
understand
pick somebody that's had a real str i
know friends that have struggled
way more than that guy
don't sell me struggle
with not a struggler
you better attach a struggler to
struggle daddy
or i'm not buying it so if you want to
sue netflix for anything carol baskin i
think at least throw that
on the radar um
and i don't have to be right about any
of that
but
but yeah the rich are leaving they're
leaving
rich people are leaving
they're on their way out
you even sometime i got on southwest a
couple weeks ago there's a little lady
in there a little i think maybe chinese
lady with a little umbrella
and right out the gate i said oh i know
what's up
they're practicing their
this a test for her she's going to be
one of the finalists
she's going to make it you know
she'll be on there with elon musk she'll
be on there with uh
you know who else they got to take
probably lester holt they got to take a
brother or two
so maybe lester holt or
reggie jackson
he'll make it
who else would make the list dude
yeah
maybe a cartoon somebody
you know probably pokemon or gizza
gizzard gizzard
gizzard
somebody they'll make it
chester cheetah might make that [ __ ]
they might take a drawing animal uh
well so you're gonna need some women on
there you're gonna need some beautiful
probably betsy ross
that little
knit it and quit it boy you want to come
over
netflix and quilt baby
oh
yeah i don't know who would be on that
final vessel i you know i won't get on
it they probably won't have me on it
unless it's of a lottery drawing
but it's obvious man
elon musk's net worth has surpassed 300
billion dollars making him the first
person on this planet to reach that
milestone
the surge in musk's assets come as
lawmakers are considered a billionaire's
tax
hey
man it's getting wild baby a
billionaire's task must slam the
billionaire tax proposal saying that my
plan is to use that money to get
humanity to mars that's what i'm saying
they're they're they're they're leaving
the rich are leaving
we will be here
arguing
with robots
that are coming to vaccinate us in our
homes
people will be fist fighting robots in
their front yards people will be it will
be down to very perishable
non-perishable foods snickers
twix
um
the u.n says six billion dollars from
the world's billionaires could solve a
hunger crisis
elon musk says he will sell tesla stock
and donate proceeds if the u.n can prove
that wow
6 billion would solve the worlds
it's funny we nobody people we must not
want to solve hunger we haven't been
able to solve it
you know it's like one of those
crosswords you know sometime you pick it
up again you look at it you're like ah
try this again that didn't work
sometime you know
you got to have hunger in the world too
i think because you gotta have a next
you know you gotta if you if nobody's
hungry then
what
people sitting around just thickening
out
people sticking around us taking tums
there'll be like a black market for toms
everybody's all fat and fed
everybody's just ordering pizza
yeah
i'm going to let you know that
blue chew is the one
you know i've taken it i'll nibble a
little bite off of one
if i'm if i'm thinking about sex or if i
just sometimes you just want to feel
blood inside of your penis inside of
your wiener
and so you want that little thing to bag
up
and not not not really full just like
you're kind of sneaking some gin into a
ball game you know
you want that little
you know almost where you could p where
you could prick the end with a pen and
just
just catch you a little hit of that
make you a damn mint julep right there
um blue chew is what i'm telling you
about a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost
blue chews tablets can help men achieve
harder stronger erections
to combat all forms of erectile
dysfunction and i'll agree with that
they make that good wiener upper baby
you know what i'm saying they put your
penis on broadway
they really put your dick out though
they put your neck out
you did somebody come on steal your dick
that's how it looks enticing so it's
that kind of medicine if you like to up
your weiner and get your weiner better
and i'm sorry for saying
d-i-c-k so many times
go to bluechew.com use promo code theo
yup try bluetooth-free when you use our
promo code theo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluechew.com promo go theo to receive
your first month free and we thank
bluechu for sponsoring the podcast
mint mobile is back mint mobile
what are you chewing on it smells great
that's mint
mobile
i'm chewing on my savings
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you
in the form of mystery fees
yup mint mobile won't allow it mint just
passes on sweet savings directly
to you
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5g
network
if you're not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you cover with their
seven day money back guarantee
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month
to get your new wireless plan for this
15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free
go to mint mobile.com
theo that's m-i-n-t
m-o-b-i-l-e
dot com slash t-h-e-o cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
theo
that's wild to think that we're going
now it used to be that foreign aid
that like nation-starving nation stuff
would go to like uh
governments
for aid
and now they're going to corporations
that's that's wild when you really think
about it just show you where we are
you know if you like depressed you know
samsung is the damn
samsung
i mean damn samsung uh is the they're
they own almost everything
if you look on your own house probably
see
you know damn darren samsung is only
like who is that
you know
you look you know
you look in your wife's heart it's
probably you know
alan samsung is in there but you're like
who is what
everything's owned by tycho samsung um
what else
ea sports
tesla it's all those are the governments
now
youtube
uh it's just the rest of the stuff's uh
it's a mirage
it's a damn sand fountain you know it's
uh
it's like seeing a damn um
hot dog in a
underwater cave or whatever
so
all right let's get back into it man um
yeah some big fights coming up
that michael chandler justin gaichy
fight i'm so excited about that
i started going back to the jujitsu gym
staying in my yoga
been going to a lot of my recovery
meetings recently trying to lean back
into that and find some new new ground
um
[Music]
what else it's that time of year you
know everything feels like the candy is
gone in some ways uh with the halloween
that build up in that excitement and
sometimes i just
uh you know it's
it's like an this time you always felt
like kind of a new
there's a frenetic energy that gets into
the air
um
you know it's a new year coming you know
it's like you're
kind of finishing things up um
and yeah i want to try to embrace some
of those moments where things feel like
new and crisp and
uh
you know i want to
i want to feel some of that
so
so i'm looking forward to trying to
trying to do that some
um my hair looks like a damn pioneer of
the sun i look like the handsome son of
a uh
inbred pioneer family
that's kind of how i feel right now
and not heavily in bread like a light
dusting of it you know
kind of like you're looking around the
dinner table you're like okay there's
there's some uh
there's people holding hands under the
table that should not be
um i'll tell you
this that uh that come up by 89 vote
that was our opening song
and we got a gift someone sent in
that i'll open in a little while
all right you guys sent in some
beautiful calls and stuff i want to
thank everybody that came out to the
shows in charleston
had a beautiful
just a nice time walking around that
city
god it is
god it's nice
went over to the uh
you know there's all these different
little areas there's horses going by
my buddy's like dude you know the horses
they
a lot of them don't want to be doing the
uh tours
yeah they do
i was at a horse field a couple weeks
ago
and those horses honestly look like they
would give anything to have the
opportunity
to get out in the world and work
and i 100
oh they're free they're run on the
pasture they're not
they were huddled in the shade of a uh
very small like tree and scarecrow
okay there's like nine horses trying to
hide in the shade of one scarecrow
impossible
and
you could tell they were tired of it
you could tell they were tired overall
of just being not you know having
nothing to do so when i go i'm in
charleston i see a horse out there
working his ass off
okay
working his white and chocolate speckles
ass off
this thing was romped out this thing was
caked up too
beautiful ass
and he's out there working people are
making his days you know hey you're
doing good buddy
you know people hey what's his name
pickles hey pickle
you know they they're living the life
they got on the frickin uh
what's the thing horses have it's like a
um
it's like that gray
you know if you work for mr gray and he
makes you do sex or whatever
you know what i'm talking about oh you
can't look over here at the sex boy
you can't look over here at the sex
mister
you know what i'm talking about 58
50 areas or something
anyway he reminds me of that movie
these guys are having a great time out
there i could testify because see it
firsthand
um and yeah there's a beautiful
everything everybody for coming out
there and we went to asheville
north carolina very
very
uh it was like a wine it's like a wine
that city
it's like a why it's like hey have you
been have you ever had a wine
have you ever had a wine
excuse me would you say i can't hear you
i'm
upstairs i'm obsessed
i'm upstairs
let's get into your calls man i've been
babbling enough but thank you to
everybody that's come out we we we got a
great uh segment of tour coming up we're
hitting richmond this week in baltimore
then off for a couple days in verlington
vermont
portland maine
uh
albany buffalo columbus
baltimore you know a lot there's just a
lot on the table
and i'm here for that
i'm here for all of that so excited to
see you guys here's a couple of calls uh
we had people calling in last time to a
response to swipe society and do you
think this is the end of the uh
of the realm of time and are things
changing this is the end of
society as we've known it what's going
on if you listen to that last solo
episode we have people calling in and
then some australians i guess have
checked in let's hear
you know ceo it's ben calling from
falcon in western australia
good day ben
good day brother and i'm glad you guys
are uh doing well over there man
really happy to hear that
you sound good man good to hear you guys
are doing well over and out
i'm just listening to your podcast we
said call in if you're from australia so
here i am mate i am a
beekeeper
taking over the family business
and i often find myself
with you blasting through my earpods
working the bees and then i laughed out
loud at something and my workmate
looked at me like what the [ __ ]
are you laughing at boy
thanks for calling brother i'm glad you
guys are doing well uh out there dude
and i'm glad you guys are keeping bees
and
it's interesting that
it's really it's such a
you know it's like you sneak in you
steal that honey from them
you smoke them out you put that smoke on
them and then you steal a [ __ ] man it's
very much like uh
you know a lot of um
[Music]
probably crime like in the 70s
i would feel like you get everybody all
huffed up on that puff baby
on that freaking spliffen door dog and
the next thing you know
you stealing ever you know you getting
everything you rolling out with all the
guava
so
i respect what y'all are doing i wish
y'all didn't smoke them out i wish y'all
came in mano imano
maybe you tie a little knife to your
butt
and you and them uh
go at it you know
um
you know
just
king of the sting baby you know there's
one way to do it but thank you for
checking in man i'm glad australia is
doing well i'm glad you guys are still
obviously taking care of what's
uh you know doing what you can in the
world
all right
we got another question another uh
somebody call in from australia as
requested i just wanted to make sure you
guys are doing well over there
you know i don't have a lot of uh
you know we don't get a lot of
australian contact here
you know you look at a globe and
and you see it on there and send them
all check a globe
make sure australia's still on there
you know because like
you know a lot of big winds and big
water
you know thoroughfares over that
direction so
i'm just happy to hear you guys are
doing well out there and you guys are
[ __ ] around with bees and that's
i mean that's really it's almost like
lost you know they got on that island
and next thing you know they're you know
then people are doctoring up some
dragons so who knows what these
beekeepers are up to
that could be a warning
you know there could have been morse
code in that voicemail we don't know
because i don't know it
and that's god baby let's hear one more
australia
hey dude
this is a fan from down under in
australia i heard you
talking about australia in the last
video
wanting some more calls coming through
so giving you a buzz man just just want
to say i'm such a big fan
thank you brother
and thank you for being alive still down
there and for doing whatever you guys
are doing
you know one of the uh
international issues with australia
people don't know what you're doing
so if you told us what you're doing
sometimes i think everybody would feel
probably a little bit more
people would sleep easier
um
but let's hear it mate thank you for
calling bob i just want to say
that probably about a fifty percent of
the reason why this news your
accent man i love the accent
also
just the hilarious terms that you have
for everything it's just funny [ __ ] the
question for you is
what do you think of australians i mean
last time i was in the states
a lot of the feedback i was getting is
you know australians are tough
australians i can't bushwind
yeah
i'll tell you exactly what i feel like
about australians
i feel like you guys have served your
time
and i say that with a clean heart bubby
i feel like
you guys have done your time
whatever you did whatever your
grandparents did
and you deserve to be free
i believe you deserve to be free man
all of you almost probably almost all of
you
there's some of you
i don't know tai tui vasa you know does
you know he may still
may want to keep him locked up for
another couple weeks but um
honestly man from the bottom of my heart
i feel like you guys have done your time
and i feel like they should let you out
man and
if there's anything we can do to help
you let us know uh 985-664-9503
is the hotline and it'll be in the
youtubes as well and i don't know what
the international
capability of calling is but
they should let you call by now you get
one call don't you
even as inmates you get
one
dial
hello yeah oh okay sorry dad
next up um
oh
we had some uh
one of the topics we discussed last time
was on the solo episode was uh
it was um
it was uh hold on i know it it was oh
the end of times are we getting towards
the end of society
we'll check back in with that episode
right here this is exactly what it was
we're getting to the end
you're seeing i think the downside of
uh
the comforts of a capitalist of maybe
capitalist america i don't know that i
don't know enough knowledge
to know that
but we could be coming to the end of
you know every period of history has a
time
mesologic
uh game of thrones
dragons
uh
columbus
nasa
and what are we in now dude
i don't even know really freelance
so
you're seeing you know everything kind
of goes through its time and i think and
this could be what you know
i don't know do you guys think we're at
the end of times as far as like what
american society has been like do you
think or do you think we're just going
through a little transition period and
it's going to come out bigger and
brighter
um
what do you think on that i'm curious i
wonder sometimes is
you know
are we stuck in this
in this swipe society where we're just
we're literally just swiping for things
that we want
whether they're human or a human
food
uh
instacart
heart where look at all of it is
is
we have access to it all
and so does it all lose its meaning when
it's
right there if you wake up with food in
your mouth man it's
then the part of you that wants to eat
it'll die i think
not the part of you that swallows the
food but the party that wants to eat
but more so the part of you that wants
to hunt
and you guys had a couple calls and
thoughts that came in and i appreciate
it you know i like to try and keep this
as a conversation if we can here and
there and so here's a couple of uh of
calls that came in
hey what's up theo
this is ryan
sitting on a bench under some nice trees
in san diego
that's called being homeless bubby and
you're welcome to do it dude
you're welcome to do it bro
onward proud of you
um listening to your podcast
and um
you were just talking about swipe
society and
you know are we gonna come back from
this or you know
is this is this the last stop on the
train line
uh personally i i think things are
things are kind of dark man um
not right here under the tree but just
in general um
you know americans who don't know each
other seem to hate each other
and
you know robots are taking our jobs
um
yeah we're
yeah i mean you described you you just
described every mcdonald's in america
right there let's hear more
all [ __ ] addicted to this piece of
glass in our pockets
magic orb very addicted to the
to the orb baby that's samsung
donny samsung and his daddy onward
can't look to the right or look to the
left and have a conversation with the
person next to us
so um that's not good but on the other
hand i don't know
it's not all bad like your your show i
think is amazing i think
it's like you're just doing good work
oh thank you man for saying that um
and i didn't mean to cut you off i don't
it's hard for me to hear
nice things about myself uh
i appreciate them though and it's
selfish for me to not even let you say
them isn't it isn't that selfish
i noticed that about myself somebody was
saying something nice i'll stop them
i don't want to hear it man
not because i don't believe them not
because i don't you know
but i think sometimes at a core space
inside of me i don't
i don't want to hear you say something
nice about me because it would
conflict
with what i've always felt about myself
which are not nice things
um
and i'm not saying that as like a cry
for help or anything like that i'm not
saying that you know
i'm just trying to share sometimes i
like to examine why i think and feel
things it's
it's the only
it's one of the ways i can use to feel
differently
so
but when you said that it hit me a
little
and then i stopped i don't want i don't
want to hear him say something nice
because if i hear him say something nice
then i'm going to thank man
what if that's true what if i actually
am a good person
that would go against all the bad wiring
that i've had inside of myself since i
was little
that i'm not good i'm not good enough
i'm not enough
and i'm not saying i'm not like it's
hard to talk about these things and not
have people think
that i'm like in some place like well
like
i'm not about to slit my i'm not in some
desperation space
but all my life i've felt like i'm not
good enough
i think that's a common feeling
for a lot of people
and i didn't really notice until just
then
when i stop i didn't want to hear you
say something nice about me i appreciate
it
i really do ryan it's nice of you to
listen
you know
it's nice of you to be in the park under
the tree it's nice you to be on
unemployment
but
um
but yeah i just realized that when i
said man i want to hear him say
something nice about me
and then i realized man a lot of times i
don't i have trouble hearing people say
something nice about me
and then i realized because if i hear
them say something if i let it sink in
if i believe what they're saying
then that's going to go against these
little
these things inside of myself
that uh that i've always thought i was
no good
which are things that i learned at a
very young age or whatever
um
and which are things that that have
motivated me most of my life
oh
so it would be under you know so anyway
this is kind of a lot there but it's
just interesting man that just kind of
happened on your call but uh
yeah man it's you know yeah we have too
much anxiety we're afraid everybody's
just fighting on the everybody's afraid
to even say what they want
the me you know these corporations
samsung uh
what else youtube frigidaire
they're the ones that own you know they
got us
they got that's they're the
they're the uh
the politicians
the politicians have plug-ins baby this
you know
tech is the new fossil fuel i've been
saying it
it's um
and here's here's something that's
interesting
with like notifications and stuff you if
you don't chat if you don't do a
check-in or if there's not you get a
thing
hey
like half my text messages are from
machines now
i'm literally communicating with
machines you know it's
it's growing whatever it is it's growing
i'm talking in the machines right now
like
we're lit it's all it's growing
and it's interesting how all the
machines hold all the info they hold all
of us
they all have our secrets they've all
anytime you've ever said the n word or
said the
f word or said the uh
l word you know
you know if you told somebody you loved
him or whatever you know it's like any
of the things you say that
the machines have heard them
so it's crazy that what like if they
wanted to they could be keeping everyone
or many many people
uh
they could be keeping many people you
know
captive you're everybody's just gonna be
sitting around waiting for the machine
to spit out something that they
shouldn't have said
you know me man i've said it all
i mean you just you know that
i've said it all man
do you have high interest loans or
credit card debts hell yeah you do i've
met half of you
with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily and
start living your life
if you're carrying a credit balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never ending cycle of debt
with no end in sight
upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get ahead they really
can
upstart can help it's the fast and easy
way to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online
you can check your rate out without
impacting your credit score in minutes
for loans between one thousand and fifty
thousand dollars
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
t-h-e-o
that's
u-p-s-t-a-r-t dot com slash theo
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application upstart.com
theo look fitting health in your routine
that's key
that's major key man you got to fit that
health into your routine you need it
well
peloton
they're ready to help you
the new peloton bicycle the original is
now 400 less
never been a better moment to commit to
your fitness goals
at a better cost that's it experience
motivation like never before with the
peloton bike
go to one peloton dot com to learn more
that's o n e
p e l o t o n dot com to learn more an
endless variety of live and on-demand
cycling classes live and on-demand
strength yoga and stretching classes off
the bike you'll keep coming back for
more that's one peloton.com
let's get another call that came in in
this response to swipe society and that
sort of deal let's go
yo
this is eddie here out in boise idaho
boise
god it's nice
if you ever want a damn breath of fresh
air man
actually a breath of fresh air sounds
disgusting doesn't it
i just want fresh air i don't want it
coming out of somebody's freaking pie
hole
i don't want it coming out of somebody's
little tater tot cabin
cavern i just want fresh air
a breath of fresh air god
um but whatever i'm making this about
nothing uh eddie
onward brother
uh dude that'd be awesome if you came
out here
originally from
uh huntington beach california
part of the mass migration out liquid
death you guys gonna buy me a new
computer what
oh man
sorry i just spilled a ton of liquid
death for the second time on my computer
ugh
damn we just got this computer this
isn't even mine
oh
i hope he got that little
might need a new gasket on this [ __ ]
damn
onward out of that hellhole communist
state uh and
yeah man i think you're right about
the end times you know the the last
chapter
uh the last book which is revelation
uh i know you said ephesians but um
it is revelation which i'm sure you knew
that
but uh i didn't know that brother but i
appreciate it revelations
i'ma look at that man
i'm gonna look at that i'm sure it's on
uh
audiobook as well onward
yeah man i i think it's a great question
you ask about
um
is this the end of american society as
we know it and i think that they uh the
evil powers that
are at hand are doing everything they
can to make sure that it is you know
they don't want a stable society
yeah that's ronnie
that's uh donnie samsung that's
um
you know hiroyamamoto
taiko you know
lance tycho i think it is or whatever it
is jeff bezos
uh
who's the other guy alan tillemook or
whatever all of these [ __ ] onward
they don't want a stable society you
don't do what they're doing to create a
stable society everything they're doing
is intentionally being done to
destabilize uh i'm flooding our country
with people that are from here that are
from other countries that don't share
the culture that you know in a lot of
ways are
not coming from stable places not coming
from places where
you have um
a a healthy society
yeah you know i agree with some of that
man i agree with some of it i you know
it's tough because you want your place
to be a welcoming place
you want your home to be welcoming you
want your home to be
a place that's welcoming
where the fireplace works and where
there's food in the cupboard for
somebody if they're hungry that kind of
place you know you want a welcoming home
um
but you also you established a country
with
certain institutions and
and beliefs and
uh you know
you know rules
and you live by them you grow up living
by them you grow up
honoring them and believing you're
honoring a system a greater system
um
and
yeah and then they make rules that don't
then they they
you know certain groups have certain
desires
and they manipulate them
and they take advantage of them
um
[Music]
and after a while i think it does leave
some people who have been playing by
trying or you know nobody's perfect but
i think
trying to believe in the rules believe
in the systems believe in
you know who have been playing by the
rules
it leaves you
feeling cheated i think in some ways
now this is also coming from uh
i mean i'm a semi-white you know i'm
polish nicaragua when i
you know grew up in extreme poverty um
but nothing's ever been handed to me in
my life
ever
jesus christ
and that's fine
you know you want those you dogs you
want that that um that diversity or the
adversity
um
but yeah i think it's it's definitely
interesting man it's definitely
it's now what it feels like america's
now this like
an llc like a shell corporation for
these darker arts that are going on
you know and we used to be able to get
upset at people as a group that that's
one thing that kind of burned me some
like even after 9 11 it was like well
you know the media's like well you can't
be mad at any of these country you know
it's like
uh
it's like we you know with a
with the
um
[Music]
the bat thing
proactive or whatever
uh
corvid
with the uh coronavirus
you used to be able to give oh [ __ ]
china you could say
somebody made either some rich white
people made it over there trying to [ __ ]
around or somebody made it
they're over there batting around
they're over there you know smoking dope
and [ __ ] eating bad ass or whatever
and now everybody here's got to wear
master tears you used to be able to get
upset like [ __ ] them
but now there's like every you know
there's one chinese guy on twitter who's
like we i didn't do it
and so the media they use that they how
it's like
you're not allowed to be
everywhere every other place is allowed
to stand up for their beliefs and their
rules
and their countries it seems like and it
feels like we're not allowed to stand up
for ours sometimes
and maybe that's just
maybe the truth is that we are
and we just need to
stand up more you know
that's what i wonder for myself
and that doesn't mean i want to live in
some type of unwelcoming place but
um
[Music]
but definitely the fabric and the
textile of what i've always thought
like the pride i've had in in a lot of
americanism um
in the good parts of it i feel like
uh
man that fabric's really been stretched
in a lot of ways
um
and it feels like my darker interests
that's what it feels like
and i know the dark arts baby you know
what i'm saying i was born in them
you know i've had spiders in my lungs
dude i know what's going on
and uh
yes so who i mean this could be the
problem and now there's no other land of
just bowed off to
you know
maybe australia maybe that's why that
guy called maybe you know send a b dawg
send a b
um
but
i don't know or maybe there'll be some
type of revolution or you know maybe i
don't know or maybe everything's fine
and this is just my perception
maybe uh you know
i don't know
let's take another one here
what's up d.o
bird man
hope you doing birdman put that [ __ ] in
the trash can leaving my saw your dough
on my
shout out manny fresh bruh
shout out uh
um
chopper
shout out wayne all of them man
gang
well brother
you know you were asking uh
in your last episode about
if we think this is the end of america
as we know it
i think a lot of people are wondering
that for the united states as we know i
think a lot of people are wondering that
but i think the truth is man
the united states was an experiment from
the beginning
um
with a lot of different hands in it and
people from all around the world
converged here
granted there were already people here
but
people converged here and it's been a
melting pot we've called it a thing and
we
you know we've called it a free nation
we've called it many things but
honestly it's been evolving since it
began
i mean
when it began there wasn't much free
about it for some people
and he's talking about the chesapeake
and the damn uh
who else chesapeake all of them native
americans i did a rod
onward
there was a lot for you about it for
others
um
and i think the same could be said for
today
i think the america that we see today
is completely different than the one we
saw
10 years ago and that different from the
one 20 years before it and so on
um
party squat you know
loyalties change
money swaps hands
yeah i think it all has a great point
it's always been evolving it always been
an evolving thing and i've only known
one segment that's one thing that's
tough sometimes as a as a human with a
limited uh
ls
uh lifespan
that i've only known one segment
i if i'd have been alive for 700 years i
might have a different view on stuff
i might be able to look at
the longevity
but i can't do that because i can
my brain only thinks in this frame
which is such a limited thing about
the existence we have because we are a
lot of our perspective is based on just
the that 67 you know the whatever year
time frame
whereas man if i could get my brain to
know a thousand years three thousand
years
then it might be wow well this is okay
maybe i see some longer
projection i see some different
possibilities i see something
oh i see what's going on here
um
you know and this so so this stuff's
just my perspective
and you may have some different
perspective uh
and that's good and that's beautiful man
and
and that's
you know everybody's allowed their own
um
but it did used to i think it used to
feel different i just sometimes i'm just
not sure
oh
let's see what else man dude we had some
other great calls that came in um
i wanna
you know what uh
let's take a call
hey theo
um
this is a tanner from oregon
and uh basically i'm just calling for a
little advice here
um
so i'm 19 years old
and my dad just died he just suddenly
died
unexpectedly just got real sick and like
in the course of a week he just uh
just got too sick and we took him to the
hospital and he passed away there
um
right i'm really going through right now
um like i've just been like real like
drinking and smoking and
i don't know i really don't know how to
deal with it
um
i'm trying to stay away from those dark
arts
so
yeah man if you got any advice on how to
like deal with unexpected uh loss and
like grieving
um loss of a loved one
um that'd be really helpful
gang brother thanks for calling tanner
and tanner that's a name they uh
you know you wanna do some leather you
wanna blackface some leather or whatever
darken up a leather
they use tanner for it
see you guys got a job you're employed
right out the womb man that's nice
you know
you know different people you know their
employees sammy he gets you know
he gets to work at the delicatessen
different people that name has that
built-in job but um anyway man enough
about that
dude i'm sorry for your loss man i
really am
you know uh
you sound like a decent man
and if you listen to this show i think
you're a good person honestly and i say
that because i just have a proof of
meeting people that listen or a part of
this community that honestly are just a
lot of good people dude god
i mean my mind and heart are blown away
a lot
and uh
um
yeah i'm just sorry i appreciate you
sharing what's going on and
sometimes you gotta burn that goat a
little
you know sometimes you feel you know
death it gets in it that pain you know
i remember when my dad died dude i just
i think i was 16 you know and i just uh
i was so angry man
that life had take you know just that
i felt like i didn't have anything and
this and then this guy
i think sometimes i felt even bad for
i don't know uh sorry i'm trying to i'm
not gonna go into my own [ __ ] here um
man i bet he was real proud of you i do
know that
i could just tell by your voice man you
sound like a like a you know
a decent guy and
um
man
imagine what was going through his head
it must have just been scary and
i bet he's proud of you being 19 he got
to see you really kind of come into you
your arms getting longer get a little
facial hair
you know and become a little bit human
um
and to have feeling maybe able to have
these feelings
and i don't know how to exactly deal
with them i think stay off of that dark
dust
you know stay off that fentanyl stay off
of that
uh but if you got to burn the devil's
hand a little bit with some liquor you
got to burn the devil's hand
with a cigarette or a dope
little dope cigarette
do it
you know uh
you know you didn't you're not an addict
i mean you didn't say you are
but you know what i'm saying
cook that [ __ ] pain away man
you know sometime when life gives you
pain you just gotta put that [ __ ] on the
damn grill
and some of them that recipe is alcohol
and
cigarette and that and do you a dope
cigarette and burn it up
but uh
love you bro
you know and i know this isn't real
sentimental maybe or doesn't feel like
it i'm i'm having trouble probably
getting into some of my feelings but
just want to let you know that you're
thought of and um
and it puts some things in perspective
because you know it's about what we can
what can we touch what can i
you know yeah there's all this is
american society changing our things
changing it's always been changing where
do we do how do i do what's
and
then here you are and this is like a
real tangible thing
you know life still means something and
we control what we can
control and i hope you got some time
with him uh to at least talk with him
before he uh
before he went on and you'll see him
again baby
you saw him here and look where we are
you know what
there's flamingos here bro so you will
see we'll see him again man
you will see him again and that will be
a beautiful time brother
um as always hotline 985-664-9503
i'm going to get on out of here we're
going to call up a single mom and we're
going to we're going to touch what we
can control
you know and i want to thank our patreon
supporters uh for providing us the
opportunity to uh do something nice for
single moms
um
you know we also uh
any shows that we're selling tickets for
there will be the first pre-sale will be
on uh patreon um
i feel like that's kind of fair
uh and then it'll go podcast and then
it'll go
uh to everyone so
um
so yeah those will be the steps moving
forward for show tickets being sold
you know we were on a slow ship over
here
um
somebody robbed our studio
in los angeles
uh
and stole some
cameras and stuff like that still
figuring out what was taken uh
but we work with what we got we touch
what we can
um
and yeah i'm just grateful for you guys
man get to go to these places coming up
richmond baltimore i'll see you guys
this weekend uh next week we're out in
uh up in uh portland maine burlington
vermont albany dude
um
we went to wilkes-barre
damn i mean
it's just been a joy you guys coming out
bear with me as i'm figuring out this
new set
it's dice i mean it's
um
it's been an adventure though it's been
an adventure so
let's touch what we can touch today uh
and check we got let's give let's give a
call now to this um well let's see who
submitted this thing let's see who
submitted this single mom here
hey theo my name is daniel and i'd like
to nominate my best friend jenny for the
single mom nominations i believe that
jenny deserves this nomination because
she is a great person an amazing friend
and an exceptional mom
she works and studies full time to
become a massage therapist and to shape
a better future for herself and her
daughter
jenny is an amazing role model
she taught me that no matter how life
gets and how difficult [ __ ] may be you
just put a smile in your face and keep
going because nobody else got you and
your loved ones beside yourself
jenny had a very rough upbringing that
what i personally think would really
break a person
but she pulled herself out of the dirt
and shaped herself to be the person that
she is now
uh she's an amazing role model for us
and our friend group and we really love
her to pieces um believe that this girl
does deserve something amazing coming to
her uh i appreciate you letting me
nominate her gang gang
gang baby thank you very much for the
nomination and that fellow beautiful guy
right there looks a little bit like
you're in vander sloot kind of but um
obviously healthier and doing better
than that guy um
and
thank you this guy's obviously
want to say i'm i want to say amish but
i think i'm i could be
i could be wrong and he could also be i
mean [ __ ] the guy could be from damn
uh
fort wayne who knows her name is janie
she lives in winnipeg canada there you
go that's what i was hearing in that guy
a little bit of canadian
a little bit of hidden white
um
she's in school full time to become my
massage therapist
awesome
oh that's sweet
she's currently saving for a car to
drive her daughter to daycare she's
currently taking a cab ooh
hard to find a cab even these days you
know a lot of times you got to know
somebody that smokes cigarettes or
somebody that um
you know has been in a domestic dispute
and is getting back on their feet
to even i mean those people usually
drive cabs
or people some people will leave their
family it used to be a man would leave
his family and
get into the tat in the cab business
you know and he'd be taking you
somewhere and he'd be like i had a
daughter
you're like ah
i'm late for bible study sir
uh janie has a daughter
penelope let's give her a call to say
hey
hey hello
hello hey janie how are you doing
i'm doing good how are you oh good you
look cute
sorry i was not like in a weird way or
anything like that i was just saying you
look nice
i can't hear you
um hold on we're just getting the audio
issue fixed on our own okay sounds good
okay can you hear me okay
i can hear you okay great
um so yeah so i just work on a podcast
my name's theo and i work on a podcast
and um
we have some of our listeners sometimes
submit like single mothers that like
they just we we've kind of been doing it
for a few years now and and people will
submit single moms uh that they that
have really affected their life or
touched them in some way and so we had a
listener named daniel and i think this
fella might be from another country or
continent i'm not sure
but
uh he thinks the world of you and he
just sent in a video and just
said that we should give you a call and
say hey
that's really nice of him that's really
unexpected he's kind of an [ __ ]
sometimes so that's nice to hear
i could see him having a little bit of
hidden [ __ ] in him and that seems to
be uh
you know that's the american that's just
the
maybe that's the canadian way are you
canadian
uh i'm canadian yes he's um he's
actually a russian israeli but he keeps
it here
okay he lives here now
one of those snow jews they call him up
there yeah he's russian israeli baby
definitely that's a cold cashier baby
right there um and how do you know him
have you guys ever been lovers are y'all
are friends or what's his status he's my
best friend oh
yeah that's sweet
well he obviously thinks a lot of you
and you have a child up there with you
yes i do
yeah penelope she's four
oh nice i just started vaping it's just
cbd
it's okay okay i will i'll vape two okay
yeah let's go
it's hard to get through the day without
vaping i think sometimes do you
no i agree
you don't let your kid vacant children
vape or not
no no way she doesn't even know i vape
yeah
cool mom cool mom um and how long is how
old is your daughter
she's four oh nice what does she like to
do
uh well she's very crazy and right now
she wants to be a pop star
yeah she likes to sing and dance and
she's very into um
we do a lot of like fake music festivals
in our living room
put on some youtube and dress up and
dance oh that's fun
yeah my sister wanted to be a pop tart i
remember when we were kids
and uh
she would put frosting on her back
mother says she would put frosting on
her back i remember sometimes
um
but anyway just different but anyway um
well yeah we just wanted to give you a
call and say hey uh you know on behalf
of daniel who obviously thinks the world
of you and we just wanted to give you a
nice gift we're just going to give you
750 bucks to do something fun with your
kiddo uh
so yeah y'all can go do something fun uh
what does your kid like to do
besides dancing in the living room like
if you went out somewhere
if we went out somewhere we'd probably
go bowling she loves to bowl and loves
to go to the arcades oh nice
yeah
and canada
what do y'all do oh y'all have snow
y'all have snow coming in canada
we do but it hasn't started yet we got a
little bit on on halloween it just
lasted for like 10 minutes and then it
was gone oh
maybe get y'all do sleds we do we do a
lot of sledding we broke our sled last
year yeah it might be time for that new
sled you feel me
well look we just wanted to say uh yeah
happy early holidays and um and
uh just on behalf of daniel we just
wanted to say hey and and good luck
being a mom out there
thank you very much
all right sweetheart have a good day you
as well take care okay bye-bye
oh
and that's beautiful to see there
janey with their daughter and that uh
good sense of humor
you know
thank you thank you guys for supporting
the podcast i'm lucky to be able to have
a moment where uh
yeah maybe they could do something fun
you know
maybe they go
spend some time together
and they sit there and laugh or do ice
cream or
you know
or just have a moment where they both
feel pretty good together at the same
time
and
if we can invest in little things like
that together then
that's god baby uh somebody sent this
gift i do not know what it is
um
i'm gonna open it up
we'll do a uh
we will do a um
we'll do an unboxing soon we got some
gifts that have been piling up and some
nice things that were sent this says hey
theo after listening to your podcast i
feel like i can relate to some of the
ways you feel one of the most difficult
things is feeling you don't matter
almost like your pain or struggle is
invisible i want you to know that you
are seen you're important your value you
are loved and you are enough here's a
small gift to serve as a reminder that
you are okay
recently sorry showing wilmington
delaware thank you for a night filled
with laughter joshua 1 9.
what is joshua 1 9 i don't know
we went to i think 8th bat we went to
we went to uh
8th baptist i think
so
joshua 1 9 have i not commanded you be
strong and courageous be not frightened
and be do not be dismayed for the lord
god is with you wherever you go
um
oh that's nice man beautiful picture
here of him and his his spouse and uh
gang gang brenda lane
oh i thought this was from a man well
there he goes from a woman that's even
better actually
all right thank you for the beautiful
gift
uh and thank you for the nice words you
know um
nobody in my life's made me for feel
more cared about i don't think than uh
than strangers
you know uh than you guys
and i say strangers but i shouldn't have
said that but
you know what i mean then um
the new folks
let's see what this gift is man dang
this thing better be good
now the the newspaper is good on it got
a little rat on it
a little cola wet rat that thing
been out there probably
sipping soup
you know a rat would do anything to get
a little damn soup on him god
that's god right there
this a trick box or something damn it's
like a damn trick candle
oh and here's another another little box
inside inside of a bag see this is look
this is you know it this is like one of
those bills that you know one of the
oh you know it's like one of the bills
going through congress there's so many
things attached you got the d you know
now this is in a bag next thing you know
everybody that's deaf gets a freaking
you know a new jet
um genuine leather bracelet
wow
and i bet it was a little lighter than
before tanner got a hold of it huh
oh that's good that's good right there
beautiful
thank you
thank you very much i like to have me a
little leather bracelet right there
it's like having part of a pet on your
arm
praise god
okay that's a sweet gift and i'm going
to keep this card somewhere nice
and this computer will short out soon
let's go out on uh
you know i'ma go out again this song
this song i i don't know how this song
does this for me
but i've never felt like a song
never in my life have i felt like a song
uh
i mean this is that ema if you want to
have some feeling you want to sit right
there in a damn rocking chair with your
broken heart
this one will do it you know with if
it's you got to be in that mood you
can't listen to if you're trying to get
hyped or something you're going to the
arcade or you're going to do a little
bit of sex or
you know you stole a bicycle and you're
going over to some girl's house or
whatever to try and get a little
little cookie you know
a little bit of uh
that little snot cookie you feel me gang
baby all right um thank you guys for
being a part of my life
and be good to yourselves and uh you
deserve that
and i'm gonna try it too thank you for
this nice gift thank you guys for coming
out in wilmington uh
thank you guys for not giving up on me
and uh to everybody that called
oh
let's keep it going man we got each
other that's something we do have
i believe that man um
all right this is evan bartell's
lonesome off the uh album lonesome
and um
yeah hit the hotline if you need
something 95-664-9503
and um
[Music]
what else i don't know i feel bad about
leaving kind of
but
we'll be back
you know
gang man
[Music]
we won't talk the way we used
[Applause]
[Music]
dying young
seems so much fun
[Music]
when in your mind
you're all alone
there's something in my head in my heart
a part of me
that always hurts
on my own i tend to fall apart
am i more
than you bargain for
[Music]
you don't have to say yourself
if it's too hard for you to love me
man
when i get stuck in this condition you
try to help
i try to listen
[Music]
[Applause]
your heart breaks and i feel hopeless
it's not your goal if i care
a part of me that always
[Applause]
[Music]
man
you don't have to say you're sorry if
it's too hard for you to love me damn
that line freaking grills me like a damn
fish baby
that [ __ ]
you know
i think i've always felt like that
like nobody
like i never got the pr i mean i don't
know man
like i never got the proper apology for
somebody not being able to love me
the way i needed to be um
but then you realize you don't get the
apol you know that's just part of that
is just life
you know that's just life
and the scariest thing is
that those types of things
can happen to us or we can feel like
they happen to us sometimes
somebody loved you perfectly it just
didn't land on you well
you may have potholes in your
pot
and
um
yeah
sometimes it just doesn't land on you
right
and then the scariest thing is how do
you do how do you then move forward in
your life and not do the same thing to
other people
you know i've been going to this sex and
love addiction thing recently and
learning more about it and damn
i just have a lot in that space of where
uh
just there's just a lot in that space
for me
and and anyway anyway this episode went
a lot longer than i expected man um
but you guys be good to yourselves
that's evan bartels off his new album
lonesome
and the song the title song is called
lonesome i believe i don't know if
that's called what it's called but uh
but yeah dude you want us if you want to
go through your feelings bro like a damn
just a
like a just
like a rolodex
god he's got all he'll he'll dial up the
numbers straight to your damn soul right
there
he's got the one he's got the 1 900 line
straight to your damn soul praise god
man you guys be good to yourselves gang